today's topic this time I wanted to
cover for a long long time I think
mostly because for me it's been a point
that's almost made me angry when it
comes to dating I think as a society we
often tell young men and men in general
that they need to be more emotionally
vulnerable that they need to be
comfortable with expressing themselves
and what I've come to learn through my
dating experiences is that when I've
taken the time to be emotionally
vulnerable with the women I've been
seeing romantically I've seen it
backfire I've seen times where I've
shared what I am feeling with women and
I've seen them get less attracted to me
and so I decided to interview some men
to see if they had a similar experience
user management resume when they have
different phone pasilla from the palasa
sure yeah I think so yeah I get it like
I'm not that type of person but I get it
because oftentimes we we don't think we
are like this as women but we we have
very old-school ways of thinking about
how men should be my man to be crying
you know I mean I cry every 28 days of
my cycle I don't want my man to be
crying every 8:28 time with the right
people yeah always worth it even if it
ends in heartbreak the journey is worth
it always yes often often we have this
societal pressure of being a man so I
need to toughen up I hate the show and
command respect
and then willy-nilly someone will decide
well in this situation you should have
been softer calmer and better and then
the pendulum goes the other way and then
you've told now you're too soft so I
constantly I am myself Aaron currently
when I meet women I'm not sure on which
foot the dance right now
yeah women are being taught to deal with
immense anger immense desire a man's
sexuality we're being taught how to
handle those situation but we're never
being taught how to handle a man being
sad or a man being hurt or a man being
disappointed so we're used to like men
like keeping it together
I think that obviously it's societal
conditioning in growth so when you have
this perception of what a man is
supposed to be sacrificing you use that
in our video that we did together on my
channel as a collab but you talked about
the sacrifice where men have to
sacrifice their time their bodies their
safety and a lot of times their emotions
like they are the rock the emotional
rock of the family and so a lot of
people grew up never seeing their dad
cry or their grandfather whoever was the
present male force in their life and so
they associate that with strength with
being a pillar of strength and so I
think when you see a man be vulnerable
even though you acknowledge that it's
healthy for them it also starts to
create the seed of doubt in your mind
because all that you've been conditioned
to believe about masculinity says that
this pillar is not supposed to bend
break or sob I mean one of my favorite
philosophers says this that what we
often tend to do in relationships is
that we use vulnerability the wrong
times
so I'm vulnerable at your expense versus
I'm vulnerable to be informative so an
example of that is hey just so you know
when I get around bright lights I start
biting people I'm informing you in a
vulnerable sense I'm informing you
before the thing has happened versus the
light went on I started biting you now
you're hurt and now I'm trying to
explain to you why it is that I bite
with bright lights okay so that happens
a lot where people have to then be
emotionally available for somebody who
has harmed them okay you're expecting
empathy from somebody whom is your
attacker
let's interested no no I love someone
who's like open and it's sharing their
life stories depends on what you're
opening up about if that's something
like say it's a it could be also a sore
spot for that person to deal with if you
engage in a relationship and it's
starting they may not be at a point yet
where they're ready to hear some
information about your personal life and
that doesn't mean that they're wrong
yeah you know there are certain aspects
of your stuff that you have to gradually
let people in incrementally some people
are not ready to hear about yes so
learning experiences so I respect that
for me personally I will share with
someone when I truly feel ready I had
society put pressure on me taught me I
needed to be more emotional and I hated
it but I decided to do it because I was
told that was the right thing and what I
found person is I felt like I was
violating myself and my own boundaries
in order to
he's what the world thought I should do
now I'm very patient with it and if a
girl kind of pressures me I'd like I'll
get to it when I'm ready just know I'm
not there yet
and that works better for me all loving
when our men are vulnerable and show
emotion right
well according to singer Rihanna it
depends what they're crying about
Rihanna posted this meet instances if we
get together and your ex died and you
cry you single somebody says and you
start weeping everything I think if you
have such uncontrollable emotion when it
comes to that person that you can't even
control it to not do it in front of your
current spouse that you might still have
some type of feelings for that first one
hundred thousand percent I agree
[Music]
so you okay hold on I've often heard
women say I've had to see him cry on a
wedding day or this animate the won't
feel special mm-hmm and sometimes I
often feel like mends and motions are
almost fetishized yes by women in the
sense that they oh he let me see that I
feel special
yeah it's only letting me see that and
so what do you realize that there isn't
that much space for men's emotions in
those relationships and it's crazy I see
a lot of older couples and you'll
realize in a lot of older couples the
man never speaks
the man rarely says anything and the
woman takes up all the emotional space
in the conversation am I wrong no the
women take up all the emotional space
and the guys are just kind of understood
that their emotions are secondary and so
they keep to themselves I'm not saying
this to criticize women this is like me
trying to tackle this issue because I'm
trying to understand what I'm going
through and what society is telling me
and the reality I keep facing and what a
lot of men keep facing and so what you
realize that there isn't that much space
for men's emotions in those
relationships it's more so about the
woman getting to feel special and so
almost deep values the male experience
and perverts it
that's something I've experienced before
this is why I think I probably would
exist on both ends right like there's
going to be times that we all enjoy or
delight in someone's pain if it's
directly
that makes us feel better about
ourselves for example I went to go see
the Joker
and in the Joker I sat beside a Joker
wannabe and this is a joke now but I was
balling in two theaters because this guy
I'm in I live in America and he had a
black backpack that he sat on his lap he
stared at me for the bulk of the film he
said to me at one point I just wanna see
you're gonna react to this point he knew
the words the movie before the words
would come out he sang along to the
songs he would say the punch line before
the Joker to the punch line when you say
for the whole movie because I felt like
if I got up cuz even my husband was
sitting beside me and Jared was like do
you need me to move but I'm like I felt
I was responsible for the livelihood of
the theatre I felt like it did not feel
empathy from me I felt like if you
didn't feel empathy for me and didn't
see me cry that he would blow everybody
out let me tell you it was one of those
fears with the reclining chairs if i sat
my chair up he would send his chair up
take your second I think you were
dealing with a psychopath
yes that's not indicative of the regular
experience I should've two girls like
collecting them I like see women got
problems like aside from that though we
get out of the theater and my partner
and then his brother was there as well
too like he embraced me and then we were
just he was just like in that moment
getting to protect right like getting to
be that so I think that in those moments
and that oh she feels safe around me
like Brooke having this moment I think
that that's what a woman's emotions is
seen as like sexy okay I've never I've
never looked at a woman who's vulnerable
or that we can say I want to hug that's
like I just want to make sure she's okay
that's it literally I never thought like
this is attractive or I feel special I
know it was just like I want to make
sure you're good that's but maybe some
men think that I think that if a man can
be in a protective position it'll feel
like they're shielding you and then
that's an emotional release from you
there is some pleasure in that because
they feel like they're getting to in
turn give you support protection so I'm
just saying that might be an example I
think the example I first gave
spot-on but you made me go to the second
one wage what about the kid yes that's
spot-on one you'll be done again when a
child cries because they're going to
school and have to be separated from
their mother and as much as you don't
want your child to feel sad there is
something pleasurable about their
sadness because you know they just love
they love you so much hmm so in that
sense like I said I guess that's a good
example yeah I would say that thank you
it sounds good
I'll see it like I'd come and open
myself but my feelings would be directed
in another way I feel like my feelings
were used to strenghten another argument
that for that reason I don't open up
about my [ __ ] because most people when
they're good not then I have they're not
gonna have any resources they're gonna
use that against you I mean I had one
girl I was briefly singing you guys
remember this video potentially but I
told her anything that my father wasn't
in my life any longer I didn't explain
to her how but he just wasn't in my life
and in a heated argument where she was
screaming at me and I was being very
quiet at one point she said this is why
your father walked out on you because
you're nothing in life not knowing that
my father had passed away and so she
said that and she used my secret against
me and I was just like okay cool I
understand what that is you know what
though like there's it's a double-edged
sword because at the same time if you
want to have you know really powerful
relationships with people they have to
see you in sometimes they're not most
positive light yeah and you know I get
what you're doing you're being selective
as to preserve yourself but in order to
be able to be as open and to have the
best relations in people you have to
have that kind of debt and sometimes I
don't need to open up something I don't
need to say all my sees I'm I don't have
anything to say like I'm just gonna say
some [ __ ] like yeah I rap these
conversations with some of my friends
like yeah I said a lot of [ __ ] I said a
lot of [ __ ] like I opened up to you I
opened up to you but you don't never
open up about my life yo maybe I don't
need it yeah it's not like it's not give
me a secret I'll give you a secret
relationship because I'm here if you
need
I'm here yeah but doesn't mean I have to
reciprocate this is a straight fax your
life expectancy decreases the less
emotional outlets that you have unless
you express yourself less outlets you
have for healthy expression of stress in
addition your culpability in the
workplace is going to decrease
especially as we have more jobs taken
out by robotics and now the only
resource that humans really have left is
our ability to work together and our
ability to work may be in very light
sedentary environments on team-based
projects and/or creative projects and so
your femininity your vulnerability is
integral to your survival in the
workplace okay and then on a third basis
like it makes for a healthier
relationship full honesty like there's
definitely a time in my life it's like
10 years ago where men have shown that
the partners I was with like shown
vulnerability and I thought it was funny
and I didn't think it was masculine and
for me it was the sign of weakness the
more I work on myself and the more that
doesn't scare me so much anymore it's
actually strength you know because we're
part of the patriarchy we're just as
active in it you know I mean like I
think and that's it we're just
participating in that too but then we're
like yes there's totally the double
standard we were like hey show you
emotions and then when they do we don't
know how to how to deal with it I I
think it's true I think they might be
having some backlash and backfires on
that because we do want men to be more
vulnerable but at the same time it's
like oh don't be too vulnerable I don't
like this now I'm not attracted to you
you have to acknowledge that maybe you
went too far with it sure yeah that I
definitely looked at that possibility
well I mean that's what it's all so hard
to know what's too far with what person
I feel like if you're starting a
sentence of like it all began when I was
five yeah no one's going that people I
think that I I can tell you this only
from a standpoint of I look at the abuse
people put on me abuse is a don't have a
better word for it but if you went
through my DMS right now yeah I
literally used to have in my info box
please no DMS because it is just P I'm a
complete stranger on the Internet
with their nonsense exactly not nonsense
but real problems like accounts of abuse
accounts of manipulation like and just
paragraphs on paragraphs now my I'm a
stranger in fact of what they're doing
in today exactly how I feel you I get
you oh just peachy go get a therapist
and no not with services not a sponsored
video but like better helper talk space
you can choose rates you can actually do
what you do by your phone you can do by
text messaging which is fairly cheap but
there's a lot of very accessible ways to
get help in a licensed professional who
is pay to and equipped to help you with
your problems and issues I think there's
a misconception that men aren't capable
of being emotionally vulnerable I think
we quite are I think those spaces
however where we are vulnerable are
reserved mostly just for men and I think
the big reason for that is that we
communicate between each other in a way
that's palatable and and easier to
digest and I don't think that happens
just along gender or sex lines it also
happens along profession social class
you know education levels like there are
certain understandings that you will
have if you have a certain live shared
lived experience you know I was in the
military before and the way we
communicate amongst military personnel
is very different than the way we
communicated with civilians we would
have conversations in the military that
if a civilian would hear they would find
abhorrent but you have to understand
your environment shapes you it shapes
your language and so as a result the way
we talk may seem abhorrent to them but
because we understand what kind of
environment we were raised in and shaped
in there isn't that weirdness or that
kind of judgmental feel that comes from
it their language isn't necessarily our
language the same way with the way women
communicate amongst each other isn't the
same way that men communicate amongst
each other so I think that's why there's
this perception that men aren't
vulnerable we are just not when you guys
are around and I've always thought it
odd when people said men are emotional
actually scientifically speaking men are
far more emotional than women we just
don't express in the same way and we are
far more I guess it's almost like it
feels more intimate this is just a
theory a sidebar I think men treat
their emotional sanctity the way a lot
of women treat their sexual sanctity
meaning if a woman has sex too fast
oftentimes they can feel cheapened if a
man reveals his emotions too fast
oftentimes he'll feel like he cheapened
himself and so I've had times where I've
shared before I was ready and I almost
felt like I hoard myself out
and so when you aren't ready to go to
that place and you're pressured into it
you feel cheap and as far as the
solution goes I don't know what it is I
just wanted us to kind of start that
discussion to ask ourselves do we really
want men to be emotional what does that
really look like are we ready for it and
what are we gonna lose if we encourage
people to go down that what is it gonna
look like for relationships for people
who say they don't want you to
traditional gender roles but actually
still live by them in a lot of ways
these are all kinds of questions that I
don't have answers to but I think we
need to oppose and I think like preached
at preached had a really beautiful way
of saying what he thought the solution
was what do you think is kind of the
solutions to this problem we've gotta be
able to talk more the solution is the
problem we're having a problem opening
up but the solution is opening up on
both sides I mean women need to open up
about stuff may need to open up about
stuff but honestly judging the other
because sometimes one woman opened up
too much they're being deemed as crazy
and you praise you create now some time
they need to open up but would be be
without being called crazy and many to
people to open up without being called
the weak there's things that both of the
both parties experiencing and both
parties need to let know on the other
side and you can't you can't always call
a woman crazy when she's opening up you
can't always call a man weak when he's
opening up you know I mean conversation
hmm I think I think that's really well
said I don't think I could say it any
better than that
any other points you want to add about
this conversation about vulnerability no
I don't but not much
[Laughter]
so you know to add to that what I would
say is like men make sure that you have
different avenues to talk about your
emotions and whatever you're going
through not just your romantic partner
but your friends right maybe a support
group I knew I had an online forum I
used to go to about my problems a lot of
the time so whatever it might be build a
network of different things that you can
use and the last thing I would say is
thank you to Shan Shan who was down to
do this project to all the people I
interviewed who were done to open up
about their experience a big thank you
to you guys cuz I know it's not easy to
admit when you were wrong or when you
engaged and behavior that you think is
problematic but because we're able to
talk about this we can however we can
encourage people have a better
understanding of themselves so yeah
that's it for today's video leave your
comments below we want to know what do
you think about males of emotional
vulnerability had there's ever been a
time where man's been emotionally
vulnerable with you and you reacted
negatively to it have you as a man
shared what you were thinking and
feeling and had people recoil or
encourage you I want to have a really
great discussion about that
[Music]
so if you guys want to check out chain
I'll leave the comments I'll leave a
description all these kind of annotation
in the video and definitely check out
our stuff cuz I actually been Affairs
before she stood in the teams so that's
I said in the DMS I did yeah the dudes
just sound like you were creeping so
make sure you just you just say I slid
into a collaborative opportunity which
sounds even worse
yeah whatever in this so today's topic
men's vulnerability so I actually have a
special guest in the building you know
that his voice changed as soon as he
started recording you got a go youtube
voice well it's funny to place it's like
hey so it's a little bit deeper yeah
okay
I'm mad at that just want you guys now a
little bit high well you know since
you're such an expert my name is Shambu
dream I go by Shambu D online I am a
public-facing sex and relationship
educator and also a fan of a band preach
I don't know why you're laughing right
now during my introduction but I can
just picture preach right now but I her
name is sham booty I want to check her
Instagram my boy Bodie with a D to play
on my last name versus the play on my
Anatomy just to keep it to manage
expectations which i think is the most
important recipe and happiness okay this
is something to talk about very quickly
how endearing it is the love that you
have for preach right because you bring
them up in conversation frequently and
you act as if he would be in the room
yeah like here's what he would say or
here's what he would like or here's how
he would react to this yeah you know
what it is it's more so I think like
just PTSD because I'm so he's still
working with him and he traumatizes me
with his like what I'm just when I'm in
front of a camera so used to having him
beside me that sometimes I'm just saying
oh this feels different
ya hear his voice again might be like
let's just send that Nick for
therapeutic reasons this is pretty right
okay all right there that's weird you're
rubbing his belly let's not do that
anymore he has a habit of her
interjecting with songs don't say a word
I'll be like I'll be like that's enough
or
say something like it's funny how
anybody it's funny how money changes the
situation like from Lauryn Hill's
doo-wop song so i hear songs every time
someone say something and I hear song
another [ __ ] it's him again he's in my
head
who's the beyoncé and the two of you do
why'd you even ask I'm not sure you know
who it is who do you think is the
Beyonce between me and priests the
reason why I say preach is only because
he is majority the thumbnails okay okay
so when you see Beyonce what do you mean
by that the lead of the group oh the
lead of the group okay I feel like I'm
what I think it'd be honest I think a
bigger personality that's what I thought
she meant so he's definitely the bigger
personality I kick up far more of the
work okay so it's kinda yells of the
group sure I don't know whose messiness
dad the dad behind the scenes some
puppies dead we keep this Bo's